你知道 Casio 嗎？就是那個做 G-Shock 的品牌。他們最近有個做法，我一開始聽到覺得蠻出乎意料的。
嗯，Casio 我當然知道。G-Shock 不是一直都是他們的主力嗎？怎麼說出乎意料？
其實，Nikkei Asia 最近報導說，當市場都在追智慧手錶、追求高端化時，Casio 反而把重心拉回他們那些被大家覺得「廉價」的基礎款手錶系列。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說廉價？一般公司不是都想往上做，把產品賣更貴嗎？把「廉價」的產品當主力，這模式撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？
沒錯，這就是它有趣的地方。他們並沒有放棄高端，但卻成功讓這些原本被「輕視」的基礎款，變成了新的主要獲利來源。
所以他們是怎麼做到的？只是降價嗎？還是有什麼特別行銷手法？
報導裡提到，這些 Casio Watch 系列的特點是「簡單又復古的設計」。重點不是低價而已，而是「設計精良」的廉價產品。
設計精良的廉價產品？這有點矛盾吧。一般來說，設計成本會反映在售價上。
不過，Casio 已經有那麼久的歷史了，很多設計可能都已經是現成的資產了。他們是利用現有資源，重新去包裝。
重新包裝…但我記得 G-Shock 最近在中國市場好像遇到一些銷售困難，Casio 會不會只是因為這樣，才不得不退而求其次？
你說的沒錯，原文確實有提到 G-Shock 在中國的銷售下滑。但 Casio 的股價是因此「回升」了，因為這個「簡單又復古」的 Casio Watch 系列需求很強勁。
股價回升？那這就不是單純的權宜之計了。聽起來他們真的找到了新的成長點。所以，對一般創業者或主管來說，能學到什麼？
我覺得，它提醒我們不要盲目追逐市場主流。很多時候，我們身邊那些「被低估」或「非主流」的產品線，說不定就是藍海。
意思是，去看看倉庫裡那些賣不好的舊產品，重新擦亮它？這點其實不容易做到，因為舊產品可能缺乏市場關注。
也不是簡單的「擦亮」，可能需要像 Casio 一樣，重新審視它的「設計價值」，用一個新的角度去定位它。他們能讓股價因為這些「便宜」手錶而上漲，代表市場是認可這種轉型的。
嗯，這確實很有意思。那我猜啦，對一般上班族來說，這概念也能用上吧？
當然。你可能工作上有些任務，或手邊有些技能，總覺得不夠「高大上」，所以把它擺在一邊。Casio 的案例，就像提醒我們，也許你那些看似「基礎」的能力，搭配新的方式，反而能發揮意想不到的價值。
好像也提醒了我們，不要太快就否定那些看起來不那麼炫目的東西，說不定裡面藏著意想不到的機會。